a place of outstanding Beauty but long
industrial Decline and as pit frames in
the Northeast turn to rust so have lives
leveling up here has become much more
complex than just investment in
hollowed-out towns
Cuts in Services community centers and
pressures on health provision seem to
have created another problem
addiction often to drugs handed out by
GPS
everybody's getting them the doctors
think it's the new wonder drug and they
can't see the problem the course and I
don't know why they can't see that
problem Justine beat an addiction to
heroin and was clean for 12 years but
says the drug her doctor later
prescribed for pain relief was for her
an even greater challenge
I says I need something like ibuprofen
but maybe it's a bit stronger and that's
when the prescribed as the pregabalin
very addictive more addictive than
anything I've ever taken in my lifetime
more addictive than heroin yes soon she
was topping up on the black market I was
taking 10 a day so you were taking three
thousand milligrams yes yes it costing
you 25 pounds yeah a day I don't know
how I'm alive
Sky News research shows a distinct
north-south divide over the prescription
of high-dose opioids per head of
population in the Northeast it's three
times higher than in London for example
a practice in Durham with fewer than 20
000 patients prescribes over a million
milligrams of opioids a month and while
opioid use has fallen slightly in recent
years prescriptions of other painkillers
such as pregabalin given to Justine are
on the increase again the Northeast and
Cumbria and outlier twice the national
average per head of population
Justine is housed by Positive Directions
which helps accommodate vulnerable
people Bev is one of its support workers
and says there's very little help
available for those suffering from
mental health and addiction problems for
the last year there's been a lot of
suicides through through drugs and
people not getting help people really
depressed can't get any help from
anywhere getting told that there's
nobody can come out to see them because
there's not enough staff
Bev is visiting Aaron another recovering
addict
in my mind it was okay to do this
because it was prescribed off a doctor
but I've paid the price I have paid the
price
Aaron asked for help after becoming
addicted to Morphine she says the one
place in Durham that treats addiction is
often Rife with dealers outside
if you really want to steer clean it's
really not the place
you know if you really want this score a
hit let's go outside of Winnie Hill
others told us the humankind rehab
center on Winnie hill was a place where
drugs were regularly sold or exchanged
outside so we decided to have a look
within minutes a social worker we were
with was offered heroin the company told
us humankind takes any reports of drug
use sharing of drugs or dealing within
our centers extremely seriously and we
have strong well-communicated policies
in place prohibiting these acts anyone
found to be dealing sharing or using
drugs on a humankind site will be
challenged and reported to the police
and any claims of drug dealing are
investigated thoroughly
however director of housing group
positive direction says the problem is
GPS are essentially creating the
clientele for a new black market
that's a time bomb that's been simmering
under the surface for quite some time
now what we're encountering is an
explosion in
you know prescribed drugs from the GPS
and certainly on the black market
um I know from speaking to numerous
people a lot of people have been
accessing drugs from the dark web
clinical academics in the region are
also concerned and the program's being
launched to contact those on high-dose
opioids offering them help Primary Care
is overwhelmed at the moment and time is
very precious in short GP consultations
and I think sometimes it might just be
easier when a patient wants a tablet for
a GP to prescribe or to continue to
prescribe a medication
indeed the head of Pharmacy in the
region says evidence on these drugs has
changed and the Health Service needs to
take note the conversation is changing
and we're starting to talk more about
non-non drug treatments non-medicines
um for the for the treatment of of
chronic pain because we know that the
the harm that can be done by opioids
certainly in long-term pain
um outweighs the benefits so we've all
got to re-educate ourselves people like
me who were educated 20 years ago have
got to change the way that we think
about things it's fair that the
populations in towns like this one are
falling into a vicious cycle of
deprivation depression and then
medication which only adds addiction to
their long list of problems there's no
help for people however they're going to
break the cycle there's nobody to break
the cycle you know of not working
they've got like no help they've got no
jobs they've got like no future that
have no dreams
this region is far from leveling up and
one reason perhaps is that pills are no
substitute for a lack of services and a
lack of Hope Jason Farrell Sky News